okay uh first and foremost before we
talk about
uh this tragic incident we really wanna
share and uh
extend our condolences uh to the father
of liam
right as parents none of us ever wanna
go through something like this so
our hearts go out to the father of liam
the victim in this case
with that i'm going to share briefly
some of the information that we had
prior to this incident on
june 1st the victim's father
called in a report that
mom and and liam he hadn't heard from
them he hadn't seen them
at that time he was not sure if he
wanted to pursue any type of
you know child stealing parental
abduction
charges on mom however he did felt
feel that it was important enough for
him to contact the police
and let them know we did take a report
and that happened on june 1st fast
forward a couple days to
friday june 4th a friend of the family
comes here to the police department and
makes us aware
of this sketch in las vegas she thinks
that sketch
looks like liam immediately
you know we connect that information
with the information we had from
june 1st and contacted las vegas metro
that got the ball rolling one of their
detectives came here to san jose
retrieved
an item with some dna and they were able
to make the match
with liam in in las vegas now i want to
emphasize that when dad called us on
june 1st
liam's body had already been discovered
on may 28th
so obviously a lot to share that will
come from las vegas
on this whole investigation in this case
again a very very tragic event
as soon as you know we were alerted that
this might be him
we had no knowledge on june 1st about
this body
and liam being found in las vegas it
wasn't until june 4th
that you know this person came in with a
sketch from las vegas that we
immediately
you know started to get the ball rolling
and reached out to those authorities
there in las vegas
so without any questions
you know i don't have any information on
what's specifically said nor i think i
can share it's you know a
police report now that's associated to
this homicide i just know that
he reported them as gone missing and
talked to them
was still not even sure at that point
that he wanted to pursue any any type of
charges against mom for
a parental object abduction etc so you
know we took the report
he felt it was important enough to come
and report it and have us document it
however he was not sure what charges he
wanted to pursue if any
did he say
i don't have that information do we know
[Music]
if there was any report of domestic
violence prior
to the incident involving the mother and
her kids we don't have any police
contacts with them in regards to family
issues
you know anything like that at all uh so
it's you know
we don't know and i'm sure las vegas
metro is digging their heels in deep
to figure out what happened here why he
did not want to file any charges or make
anything more formalized maybe just
explain a little bit more about the
process
that he asked for or if he was just
simply alerting him i think he was just
simply letting us know i mean
these types of cases they're not out of
the norm where one parent
you know comes in and reports you know
the other parent took my kid without my
permission they're out of state
you know yeah we'll certainly take a
child stealing parental abduction report
but you know very just unusual
circumstances with this he
felt it was important enough to contact
us and report it he just wasn't sure
what he wanted done
did it go down as a child stealing
before you know i don't know what it was
officially titled i mean it was taken on
tuesday
and a couple days after that on friday
is when we got the other information so
that immediately classified it into
something else
where we reached out to las vegas
sergeant was uh
did the father say anything to indicate
that he was worried about the child's
safety
or anything to suggest that uh yeah i
didn't talk to him i didn't
so i don't know what his exact words
were but i mean concerned enough to
contact the police
right i mean if he wasn't worried or
anything like he probably would have
never talked to us and waited for them
to show up
but it obviously was concerned him
enough to contact the police
do you know what their arrangement was
in terms of custody of liam
you know i don't i don't know i i think
they both share that common address in
south san jose
but i don't know what type of you know
domestic arrangement or partnership they
had
the father mentioned anything about not
wanting to get the mother
well i would imagine that's why he was
kind of wavering whether or not to
pursue any type of criminal charge
against mom
uh so that's why there was he didn't
formally request hey i want her arrested
or i want charges for
you know child stealing or parental
abduction
she was apparently you know all over the
neighboring states here and that's
something that las vegas is
investigating and handling and
we'll probably be able to share later
did they have joint custody as a child
yeah i don't know what what that
arrangement was
oh we're going to help them with
whatever we can you know as soon as we
were alerted to the fact that
this deceased boy they found in vegas
might be
somebody connected to san jose we
immediately reached out to them provided
any and all possible aid we could we
made arrangements for them to get you
know an article
that had some dna that they were able to
match and we're going to continue to
work with them in the system in any way
we can
do police las vegas officers
to the home to collect the items and if
so what are the items that were
collected
you know i don't think i can discuss
that nor do i know the details on how
and when that happened
i do know that an item was provided to
them with dna that they were able to
match
i don't know do you have anything
again that's a question for las vegas
metro
i don't have that information either i
mean
eight years old kovid i don't know what
his situation what schooling was
anything else
it wasn't even a missing persons it was
hey i haven't seen them
this is you know mom this is my son
i don't know where they're at i want to
report it
so we usually we will ask well do you
want you know is this a child stealing
thing do you have custody paperwork
like i said that's not an out of the
ordinary call for us to take
you know family disputes et cetera one
person takes a child out of the county
out of the state without permission
that's it's a lot of family court stuff
so i think at that time he
his sure probably was not sure what he
wanted to do
but was concerned enough to report it
did he mention how long it had been
since he'd
seen that since he was concerned how
long had it been
i don't have that information how long
had it been since he'd seen them or
talked to them before
he contacted us on june 1st obviously he
uh
they discovered liam on the 28th so it
had been some time before then
and you're saying that they all live
together so i do know they have that
address in common whether or not they
live there
i don't is there know
video surveillance of the the phone for
example because i know the last time
that
the mother and the kid were sitting
together was
may 24th yeah that's subject to uh
that's
las vegas is handling all that we don't
want to share any information that
it's going to affect their investigation
all i wanted to share was what we knew
prior you know to the stuff coming up